Let's solve a few more problems from systems of linear equations
In this lesson, we will decrypt systems that we can
have no solution, or may suggest many solutions
and we will describe them in words
Let's start with one.
Let's say we have 3x minus 4y equals 13.
Let my other equation in the system y be equal to
minus 3x minus y.
The first thing that makes an impression is
this strange form here.
That's why I'll have to convert it
and I will probably apply an abbreviation for this system.
Let's translate the above equation.
We have 3x minus 4y equals 13.
Let's reorganize the lower equation now.
Adding 2y - will shorten y from both
sides of the equation
With this abbreviation on both sides of the equation, it
becomes 0 is equal to minus 3x minus 2y, or
minus 3x minus 2y is equal to 0.
Let's write it here from above.
And now everything looks good, because I have a minus 3x here,
and I have plus 3x here.
It seems appropriate for an abbreviation.
I have negative 3x minus 2y is equal to 0.
Now let's get the left side of this equation
with the left side of the yellow equation.
And on the right we'll get 0 with the right side
of the yellow equation, actually we
add 0 to both sides,
That is, we add the same amount to both sides
and that's what we always do with an equation.
and so on the left after we cut 3x
we will stay with minus 4 or minus 2.
Which makes the minus 6 equals 13.
We divide the two sides to minus 6.
And we leave with minus y equal to minus 13/6.
Now let's solve the equation for x.
And we can find x using each of these equations
Let's use the above, so for pleasure.
We have 3 times x minus 4 times minus
13/6 equals 13.
Now we have a minus in minus, which
gives a positive result.
then 4/6, which is the same as 2/3.
From here we get 3x plus 2 times 13, which makes 26/3, e
equal to 13.
Instead of 13 because I have to divide 26/3 on both sides
let's write 13 as 39/3
Is that clear?
39 divided by 3 is 13.
Let's split the two sides to 26/3.
The left side is 3x, which is shortened
equals 39 minus 26 is 13/3
We will now want to divide the two sides into 3
Or you can imagine it as a multiplication of 1/3.
The left got up, there we left with x
The right side is equal to 13/9.
This is how this system has a well-defined solution
The solution is x is equal to 13/9 and y is equal to
minus 13/6.
this has only one solution.
if you imagine this solution graphically, these are two lines that are
intersect exactly at one point.
And in a system like this one just has one solution
is called definite.
Everything we've been doing so far is
a certain system of linear equations. Let's get started now
something that's a bit different.
Let's have the system
5x minus 4u is equal to 1.
And minus 10x plus 8u is equal to
minus 30.
Once again, I'm forced to use the elimination method because
I have minus 10x and 5x
And if I take the above equation and multiply it by 2
will become 10x minus 8 is equal to 2, right?
I simply multiplied both sides by 2.
If we collect the left side, we will get 0x plus 0e
minus 28.
So we actually got 0 that is equal to minus 28.
This is odd.
We know that this is not possible.
Not true.
That is, we receive an insubstantial opinion.
We get the wrong result, and that's because
no solution
By solving a system of equations, it does not matter
how do you do it, whether it's by the substitution method or
by the method of elimination, as I did before.
When you get a decision where 0 is equal
the minus 28 or 5 is equal to 7 or two other things that clearly
show that they are not equal to each other when they must be equal
to each other because they are part of a system, we say
that this is an incompatible system.
And it will not have a solution.
What does this equation mean,
have no solution?
Let's introduce them graphically.
So I think you can easily imagine what it means
no solution.
So the first equation is 5x minus 4u is equal to 1.
Let me present it in the shape of a sloping cross.
And if we take 5x on both sides, we get minus 4x
equal to minus 5x plus 1.
dividing both sides to 4, equals
to minus 5 / 4x minus 1/4, right?
1 divided by minus 4.
Here's the first equation, right here
in the form of a sloping segment.
Now let me write the second equation in
the same shape.
We have minus 10x plus 8u is equal to minus 30.
Add 10x to both sides.
We will get 8u is equal to 10x minus 30, and let's divide
both sides of 8.
We will get u equal to 10/8, is the same as 5/4.
5/4 min 30/8.
30/8 is actually 15/4.
Opa, I actually made a mistake here
By dividing the two sides of the equation into minus 4.
minus 5 divided by minus 4 is plus 5/4.
That is, I did not have to have a negative answer here.
For a bit to bang.
Here we should not have a negative answer.
Then I split 1 to minus 4, and I got minus 1/4.
And let's go back to the two equations, what do you notice?
When we present them in the form of a sloping section, they have
the same slope, 5/4.
but have different y-values.
So how would their graphics look like?
Let me draw them.
If this is my order y.
And this is my abscissa x.
according to this equation, the y point at 0 is negative 1.4.
Probably this is the point here.
And this goes to 5 / 4x.
This little more than 1.
That's 1.25x.
That is, every time you move to the right with one, you will move with 1.25.
That would be like that.
I will draw it roughly.
I want you to get a simple idea.
This is how this right will look like.
Now this line, where y / values ​​are minus 15/4.
what is this 15/4?
3 and 3/4.
and assuming that this point is -1/4, the values ​​for y will be
somewhere down here.
I will do it in the same color.
Somewhere down here.
Let me go further down here.
That would be -15 / 4.
its inclination would be the same.
Each time you move the value to one right, you will
increases by 5/4, so the slope remains
same.
And what do you notice about these two lines?
They are parallel.
They have the same slope at different values ​​for y / beginning
so they would never cross.
These two lines will not cross.
Which means there is no point on the coordinate system
with coordinates x and y, to satisfy simultaneously
these two equations.
Remember, this right presents all the points you have
will solve this equation
This privilege shows all the points you have
will satisfy that equation.
Note, no point satisfies both.
There is no intersection for these reasons
this is an incompatible system
Let's decide another one,
Let's say, I have 4 x plus 5y is equal to 0, and i have 3 x e
equal to 6y plus 4.5.
Actually, let's make a little different because I want it
to show you all the different kinds that we can
visible in systems of equations.
I will delete this.
Let's say the first system is 3x minus 7y is equal to 1.
And the other equation in my system is
-6x plus 14y equals -2.
So, let's try to find values ​​for x and y that make it more astonishing
equation here.
And just to change the pace, let's make a substitution.
Though it's very tempting to make an acronym here, let's
we use the substitution method.
You take 3x.
Let's solve it for x.
Actually let's just eliminate it because it is
just so brightly prepared for elimination, let's
just do it this way.
So, let's multiply this upper equation by 2.
And what do we get?
Get 6x minus 14y equals 2, so?
I just multiplied each unit on both sides of 2.
Now, let's collect the left sides.
You get 0 plus 0.
And on the right side, you get is equal to 0.
You get 0 is equal to 0, which is always going to be true.
This type of system is called an undefined system.
So, remember when you get a clear decision, that's it
certain system.
When you get something abnormal like 0 is equal to 1 that
incompatible system.
This means that the steps are parallel.
When you get 0 equal to 0 or 1 equals 1 or something like that
that you are dealing with an undefined system.
Which really means that they are exactly the same, and even
although they may look slightly different.
And to check this out, we need to convert to
their graphic form.
So, this top row, you have 3x minus 7y is equal to 1.
Let it take 3x on both sides.
You will get -7y is equal to-3x plus 1.
Now let's divide the two sides with -7.
You get y is equal to positive 3/7 x minus 1/7.
That is, the first equation.
Now let's put the second equation in
graphic form.
You have -6x plus 14y equals - 2.
Let's add 6x to both sides of the equation.
So we get 14y is equal to 6x minus 2.
Then we divide the two sides of the equation by 14.
You get y is equal to 6 / 14x minus 2/14.
This is the same thing.
6/14 is the same as 3 / 7x minus 1/7.
Notice that they are exactly the same equation.
So if you want to find values ​​for x and y's that match for both,
think about it.
We present it graphically.
So if this is my coordinate plane, that's ax y, that
is x-axis.
This chart will look like this.
I will draw it roughly.
It may look something like where the slope is 3/7.
This right will look similar.
This right seems exactly the same.
This is the same right.
You will say, well, what are the values ​​for x and y,
to satisfy both of these equations?
This is every x and y that lie on these lines.
These are these x and y.
These coordinates.
There is an endless number of solutions.
And when we use the word dependent, because you can
take one of these equations from one another.
These equations are dependent on one another.
You can change their scale or rearrange them, and
they will still be equal to each other.
Here you have endless many solutions.
Everything that is responsible for one right will satisfy the other.
So just choose x.
When x is 1, you get 3/7 minus 1/7 this is 2/7.
So 1, 2/7 answers for both equations.
If you select x is equal to 0.
0, negative 1/7 meets the two equations.
And you can choose an infinite number of values ​​for x, the solutions
for y and these coordinates will satisfy both equations.
Let me review this a little bit.
So we only started with plain vanilla.
When you actually get a decision that is in the definite.
In fact, these lines are intersecting at one point.
Then you have a situation where you can get something abnormal,
when you decide your system of equations.
0 equals -28.
Definitely not true.
This is an incompatible system.
There is no solution, which means that
these lines are parallel.
They never cross.
And then, finally, if you get something that's always true--
It's just kind of stupid how true it is - it is
undefined system.
The rights overlap.
You can check this by entering both of them in
graphic form.